[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's jim gray
the sportscaster reporter producer
12-time sports emmy award winner and his
new book i highly recommend
it's called talking to goats the moments
you remember and the stories you never
heard available
beginning today online wherever books
are sold jim good morning how are you
i'm great dan good to see you how are
you i'm doing great where are you right
now
i'm in los angeles uh i had to get out
of my house this morning no internet no
power so i've
come across the way here to a place that
i think you know
oh riviera wow
so uh you're uh right off the putting
green above
18 there at uh riviera yes thanks to mr
yamaki for letting me come over on short
notice here
um i was just telling the danettes about
the richard nixon story and they thought
that i was talking about somebody else
named nixon here now explain the former
president
and how you come in contact with him and
start talking football
i was living at john madden's place at
the dakota he was a dear friend and
john let me stay stay at his place for a
couple of years it was like the guy who
came for dinner and never left
i was walking down the street one day
and uh
a guy pulls up in a sedan and it's black
tinted windows and the guy says to me
are you jim gray and i said yeah and i
just kind of kept walking because black
tinted windows and
i'm thinking well what's this guy want
to talk to me for so i crossed the
street and they came back around he said
you're jim gray i said we yeah we kind
of established that i am
nice to see you president nixon wants to
talk to you
and a guy rolled down the window and
there was richard nixon so i got in the
car
talked to richard nixon for 45 minutes
he knew everything about
new york football giants he knew
everything about baseball he's rather
than all statistics he's
got all kinds of all kinds of scenarios
in his head of what gone on in all-star
games so i get out of the car all
excited i come back to the apartment and
i see matt and i say
hey coach you're not going to believe
this i'm walking down the street and i
just
talked for 45 minutes with president
nixon he said
don't ever ask madden i've heard
all the s i can take from matusac and
sister
don't ever ask madden and he walks out
of the room well about a year later
i'm sitting in the i'm sitting in there
watching television madden comes in and
he says
i'm sorry i called you an s what are you
talking about coach he said
about a year ago i called janess and
guess what i just spent about an hour in
the car with richard nixon over here on
72nd in columbus
and you're living in the dakota at john
madden's uh
apartment this is right off central park
and you end up
some kind of encounter with yoko ono in
the dakota
she lived right across the way so when
you'd look out of madden's kitchen
about i don't know 60 feet 90 feet
across the way in the dakota in the
courtyard was yoko ono and she lived
there obviously with john lennon and
and he was assassinated and so you know
i'd get up and have some orange juice
and from time to time she'd be in the
window and we'd just kind of wave
she would wave back so she probably
thought i was one of madden's sons or
didn't really know so one day i'm
walking back
from the uh from the studios from uh uh
30 rock and ice walking through
ironically strawberry fields and there's
yoko ono
and she's with somebody and so i said
hello mrs
this is oh no hello yoko i'm jim gray i
wave to you all the time
and we talked and she was very pleasant
about a minute and a half two minutes
three minutes whatever it was not long
and you could see it kind of it ended
dan and so uh i said well maybe we
should have a coca-cola one time or
get together and have some coffee and
she said no
i prefer to wave
[Laughter]
so so about a week and a half later you
know i was kind of embarrassed but you
know
that's all right she was very nice i
mean she was very she was terrific
so she's sitting in the window and i
kind of waved and i was a little
sheepish because i thought maybe she'd
blow me off
she preferred the wave give me the
toughest story to tell in this book
wow the toughest story to tell
well it's probably pete rose
and the pete rose uh interview that
happened 21 years ago
um just because of everything that went
on and uh
all of the uh vitriol and tumult that
was associated with it uh
for me for him uh for the network and
for everybody involved for baseball
walk walk us through it the game plan
that you know they were they were
honoring uh you know the greats
i think was mastercard i think honoring
the greats of the game and
you were on field reporter for nbc and
what was your game plan
in talking to pete well everybody had
decided and you and you worked there for
a long time dan so you know
uh dick ebersole and sam flood and bob
costas
bob euchre joe morgan you know we had
our meeting
and we wanted to speak to pete and we
didn't really know if he was going to
speak or not then we got confirmation
that he would
and so we all had a meeting and
everybody agreed that you know
what the line of questioning had to be
it was the first time he'd been on the
field
in 10 years after having signed his own
banishment away hoping to be reinstated
but
so far that had been unfulfilled so you
know the idea was to ask him about
what had gone on in his life i saw pete
in a room
with all the greats that they were
celebrating the the all-century team
and talked to him briefly about the
interview and he said what would it be
about and i said
it's going to be about everything in
your life pete and he agreed so he said
okay
so when he came over you know just
started asking the questions
and felt that it was necessary at that
time to you know
establish why he hadn't been in baseball
and did he want to make some sort of
admission
and it just kind of careened from there
do you think he understood of how to
make himself a sympathetic figure in
that moment
make you look bad you know i don't know
i've never
contemplated that i don't i don't think
so you know
believe it or not dan after 21 years and
everything that went on
i sat down with pete rose last week and
did an interview and we're going to have
it on fox
on sunday night this on fox news on
sunday night at
10 o'clock an hour special on talking to
goats
and we talked for an hour and a half but
i don't think he was you know he says he
says in the special
that he had been playing baseball since
he was eight years old since they
determined
you know he was special all the way up
until he was 47 he was involved in the
game
and he said it was just not in his best
interest to come clean
first of all he didn't think they had
the evidence even after they had the
evidence
and he said if i would have admitted
this i was guaranteeing my own
banishment so it was just better to lie
and hope that they didn't and that it
would go away
and that it got away from it you
talked to a lot of different people
obviously the the book is called talking
to goats we're talking to jim gray his
new book that's out now it's available
online wherever books
are sold your favorite athlete that you
talk about have a story about in the
book is who
i don't know that i would have any
favorite dan i mean i've been
you know very close to a lot of guys
chuck daley was my best friend julius
irving
uh obviously opened so many doors for me
was in the wedding muhammad ali
and traveling with him and my first
interview with muhammad ali loved
charles barkley's company do a radio
show for the past decade plus with tom
brady
so it's hard for me to just sit here and
pinpoint new kobe bryant
since he was just a an infant all the
way through his life and you know still
mourning that loss and and you know he
was a close dear friend so
uh i wouldn't want to just sit here and
say any one of them but i would just say
the whole collection of them all have
been a really
really fortunate existence and and i
wouldn't trade it
what's your favorite kobe story
my favorite kobe story is probably um
[Music]
well my favorite kobe story is one that
didn't take place on the court we we
went to hong kong together
and uh there were a bunch of folks that
wanted to hear from kobe and so
there were 20 guys that wanted to hear
from them so we flew over there spent 36
hours
together did a question and answer and
after we had done the question and
answer we went to karaoke
in hong kong where only only language
really spoken there
in this bar was was chinese and we went
in there and started singing take me
home country roads
uh by john denver and he sang new york
by jay-z and alicia keys and my wife
fran was with me and
and and she was singing uh an elvis song
and we just had so much fun that night
i'm getting
chills saying this we had so much fun
and he was so dedicated to his kids and
he had been out of basketball for a
couple years at that point
maybe two or three and um he was just so
at ease
and i just never forget the scene those
people
in that karaoke bar knew very little
or no english other than the songs but
every single one of them wanted to touch
kobe bryant
every single one of them wanted to
be near him take a photo knew who he was
and wanted to be in his company and i'd
seen that with ali and i'd seen that
with dr
j and you see that with i saw that with
michael jackson
when i was with him at a fight um but
just the pure joy um that he was able to
bring those folks and
the fun that he had doing it i guess
that's
the favorite thing you know that i would
it's probably because it's also the most
recent
i mentioned this one when muhammad ali
died that his impact
on a new generation was really not
necessarily about boxing
it was about being an activist it was
about being out there it was
all the bravery that he had his entire
career and i think that that whole wave
of chris paul
and uh lebron james and you know some of
these other players
they saw this retrospective these
eulogies to him
and i don't know if it triggered
something and i don't know if you ever
got that feeling but it felt like
ali's impact on this new generation was
based off things he did outside of the
ring
i would say that's 100 accurate look at
what lebron did
in the documentary that he did for hbo
which i believe was just this year on
muhammad ali
he was the executive producer oh with
maverick carter and
rich paul and and their company randy
mims and
i think that what they saw in ali and
what we all saw in ali
and and it was and it resonated
throughout his whole life but
the courage you know the greatest moment
that i ever saw in sports
uh it's twofold but the first one has to
be muhammad ali when he lit the torch
and i was on the field that night in
atlanta doing the olympics and
bob costas and dickenberg were in my ear
and um we could hear that and you could
see that and
just the courage that it took the
bravery the humanity
the fragility of life and the pure
greatness
of that moment and that man for all that
he stood for
all of the principles everything that he
had done in the ring
and more so out of the ring it was all
there in front of us and if that wasn't
an example
uh that will live forever for good for
future generations
for everything that he did for all of us
and for the world
and i think all of those guys saw that
and all of those guys know his story
and so yes do they want to emulate that
yes and do they want to carve their own
path
and do great things yes i truly believe
that dan i know you have a great
relationship with tom brady
but i'm do you know everything that went
into that decision to leave
tampa because in the book you mentioned
that you know there were three teams
involved including the chicago bears
that tom was considering what don't we
know about that decision by tom
to leave the patriots well
what don't we know i mean i i think i
know you know i know tom
very well but i can't tell you his
innermost thoughts
i do know that his family was very
important and
i do know that the proximity of tampa
to brazil and to costa rica is very
important because of giselle and i do
know that his son jack lives in new york
and would come to the games in boston
and visit his father and he's now 13 or
14 years old
and that's very important to him so when
it came down to the chargers
chicago and tampa you know i think that
the chargers just the proximity
uh and the west coast was just too tough
for a 14 year old to be flying back and
forth you know 12
14 hours a weekend and then that
that makes it also another eight hours
for giselle to get to her family
so i think that in the end the family
was most important
and and and chicago i can't tell you why
he didn't choose chicago
and why he did choose tampa uh weather
probably had a little bit to do with it
after freezing and suffering through new
england all those years
tom seems to be pretty happy sitting out
there in that whirlpool
uh you know getting better with alex
guerrero after some of these games that
you know
the the heat is a little bit better than
the frozen cold
i highly recommend the book it's a great
read and if you want
one of those stocking stuffers in time
for christmas it's uh called talking to
goats
and it's available in bookstores and
online wherever books are sold
it's uh talking to goats the moments you
remember and the stories you never heard
and what i loved about it jim was you
gave you gave your side whether you
you know the pete rose situation the
decision with lebron
all you did was give context to a story
that i think people have already made up
their minds about
and i think even if you've made up your
mind i think you may be
you're going to make people reconsider
or look at it differently and i
uh you know you put it out there warts
and all uh these stories and i i really
enjoyed it
thank you dan i appreciate you reading
it thank you for having me on
love your show love the guys and what
i'm most happy about
you're doing great yeah i feel better
and you're out there at corn ferry tour
i'm i'm i'm ready to see it yep yep i
played golf with jim at uh
at riviera he played better than i did
there
and uh we're on the 10th hole we're
approaching the 10th green
and uh he had been talking about my
health and he goes
hold on let me call tom so he calls
brady
and he facetimes brady he's like hey i
got somebody once say hello
i'm like i what hey tom how are you and
then uh you guys talked about some other
things but
tom did send me a book thanks to you
with uh all of his workout regimen and
the diet and everything else as well so
i look exactly like brady does now tom
uh jim and
and and and i hope the tb12 method
helped you but i remember
we had a great day together too and i
remember you tried to dunk on dr j
oh out there out there in salt lake city
that was nba finals mid 90s and jim
invited me to play with dr
j and we're playing at a golf course
outside of salt lake
and there was a backup on like the 15th
tee and there was a basketball court in
a yard
right off the tee and i said doc would
you come over
and uh shoot around and doc is one of
the nicest people you ever meet
and then i said would you stand
underneath because i want to dunk on you
so we lowered the hoop to like maybe
eight feet
and i uh and dr j let me dunk on him
that day
jim you know if we all would have had
cameras and cell phones
that day boy that would have been that
would have been all over everywhere it
depends on how you framed it but if you
framed it where i was actually on a
10-foot hoot
dunking on dr j uh i could have lived in
infamy but um
thanks again and thank you as always for
your friendship and i wish you the best
of luck with the book
thanks dan thank you that's uh jim gray
forrest gump of sports reporters he's
everywhere